hey 42 here if you are feeling lonely in
Japan you can rent a Japanese
middle-aged man for $10 an hour
welcome to RIF the fourth richest man in
the world Warren Buffet is worth fifty
eight point three billion but still
lives in the house he bought for thirty
one thousand five hundred dollars in
1958 the sloppy handwriting of doctors
kills more than seven thousand people
annually air jordan shoes were banned by
the NBA
however Jordan wore them anyway because
Naik was willing to pay the fine each
game in 2008 there was a music festival
called festival of the fuc buns where
buns such as [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] and [ __ ] buttons performed it
was held in [ __ ] Austria yes that is a
real place in Moscow Russia there are
stray dogs that ride the subway trains
on the same schedule every day each
episode of Game of Thrones cost six
million dollars to produce if the US
cause its military budget by eighty five
percent it would still have the largest
military budget in the world Russia is
the same size as Pluto the record for
the longest Facebook conversation
belongs to Dubois Kazi who with his
friends have commented five hundred and
eighty four thousand four hundred and
forty four times on a facebook status
update it is estimated that the Earth's
helium supply will have run out by 2030
and party balloons will cost about $90
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you